and now live for the next three hours on
booked TVs in-depth author and former
Fox News host Eric Byrnes the author of
several books including infamous
scribblers 1920 and his most recent the
golden lad will discuss his work and
answer your questions
author and author and journalist Eric
Byrnes is journalism the first draft of
history yes and it's one of the reasons
that history makes so many mistakes
because journalism is done quickly it's
done according to deadlines it's very
often wrong and something that I have
noticed in in I understand this is
self-serving Peter but something I've
noticed in in being meticulous in
writing history is that there are a lot
of mistakes in history if you don't go
to the primary sources and I think
that's because journalism is the first
draft of history what's one of your
favorite mistakes in history one of my
favorite mistakes in history you mean in
terms of how was written I have to pass
and and let that percolate well we will
do that but from your book all the news
unfit to print you write that Samuel
Adams told more lies in print than any
other figure of his time a distinction
for which history has not only forgiven
but honored him and you'd like me to
explain a comment that incendiary
interesting I should use the word
incendiary because his lies were told
for an incendiary purpose Adams made up
incidents of British soldiers on the
streets of Boston now they were there
having their way with American women
starting fights with American men
abusing not sexually abusing but
physically abusing American children he
did it because he wanted this country to
be independent from Great Britain he had
a tremendous forum the Boston Gazette if
I remember correctly which was the
leading paper in Boston at the time and
he thought of himself as a patriot whose
whose
weapon so to speak was journalism and he
was forgiven by history he was lauded by
history because history seems to have
proven that our being independent from
Great Britain was a good idea and
therefore however we got there even if
it meant a lot of contrived journalism
means justifying end where did the idea
for all the news unfit to print come
from actually it wasn't a book that I
really wanted to do the book before that
infamous scribblers which is a phrase of
George Washington's the founding fathers
and the rowdy beginnings of American
journalism and I'm sure you'll get to
that so I won't get to it but it was
about journalism in colonial times which
was so abusive that people who think
highly of the founders which they should
would be very surprised and a publisher
I got in touch with my agent and said
can he meaning me bring that information
up to date about falsified journalism I
could and I did but by that time I was a
little tired of writing about journalism
so you're holding the book open now and
if it's because you found a mistake it's
because I was getting tired of writing
about journalism well Eric burns you
write that sins of omission in
journalism are often calculated sins of
omission are a good way Peter to tell
lies without telling lies I don't say to
you
that's a ghastly looking tie which it
isn't
I just don't mention your tie
that's hardly a sin but leaving out
major facts the presidential debates for
instance are a wonderful example you can
easily and I'm not saying people have
done this
because I now that I'm not in journalism
anymore I don't pay any attention to
them and it's wonderful I recommend it
to most Americans but if if if you are
biased toward a particular candidate and
that candidate does something foolish
says something foolish behaves in any
way in a foolish manner you omit it and
therefore you tell a lie about the
overall scope of the debate by not
including information that Stella Tereus
to your point of view what was Fox News
watch Fox News watch was a half hour
weekly excuse me very highly rated
program that analyzed not the events of
the past week but the way those events
were covered and the reason I smiled was
that Fox is a rather controversial place
and it did not reflect my particular
political views and people who were of
the liberal persuasion who watched my
show were very defensive about telling
me they liked it it would always be you
know I I I don't usually watch Fox it
just happened to be on in the background
once and we heard your show and it
sounded it sounded okay but there always
had to be the caveat at the beginning
and that was fine I understood that the
thing that bothered me was when someone
from the far right would say to me hey
that's Eric Byrnes you go get them
liberals you go I wasn't going out to
get anybody I was I had four panelists
and I was calling on them to speak
that's all what kind of topics would you
cover the topics that every other show
covered all of the Sunday morning talk
shows but we covered how they were
covered and the two liberals on the show
there were four panelists two liberals
on the show
strangely enough always found
conservative bias and vice versa
but we were all friends
I tried to be especially light-hearted
witty comical in the in the dressing
room so that we always in the green room
so that we always went out on stage in
good humor and we never really in the
ten years that I did that show we all
liked each other so there was never
there was never the kind of
contentiousness that you see on so many
other shows I don't want to talk about
television much and I hope you don't one
thing I want to say about Fox is that
people misunderstand what it has done to
journalism there is nothing wrong with
having a television network that has
programs on it that slant to the right
there are newspapers that do that
magazines that do that radio shows that
do that what Fox did that was more
harmful to the society was it introduced
a degree of contentiousness and
argumentativeness to an interview that
had never been there before and made
civil discourse uncivil did the show end
well I ended I had a contract that
wasn't renewed and the show went on for
a while and I'm told now that it's not
on but there is a there is a show that
does the same thing but it has a
different name I don't want the other
things I've treated myself to in
addition to political ignorant is I
don't watch television very much I mean
if the Steelers aren't playing I'm not
watching well therefore the Super Bowl
is just three hours of filler to me
well Eric Byrnes you'd say you don't
watch it but you spent a lot of time in
television at Fox at NBC at KMSP up in
Minneapolis st. Paul
and you write about television your book
invasion of the mind Snatchers
televisions conquest of America in the
50s in your view does Philo T Farnsworth
deserve a statue in the Capitol as he
has
well if considering the influence that
television has had in this culture yes
most people don't know that I mean with
any invention including the lightbulb
the automobile it's very hard to say who
the inventor was you know Henry Ford
didn't invent the automobile there were
light bulbs before Edison the people we
tend to credit as the inventors are the
people who got something working to a
certain practical point of view and
Philo Farnsworth did that with
television and when he wanted his rights
his his patent and copyright rights he
came up against
NBC's General David Sarnoff who had more
money more money means more lawyers and
even back then it was the same the legal
system was the same as it is today if
you had enough lawyers and you had
enough money you you you won the case
and Sarnoff is regarded as the father of
television and stepfather is the most
that I would give him Philo T Farnsworth
came as close as any one man to
inventing television and one of the
things that I liked about that book and
the book is to me is is not so much the
invasion of mind Snatchers Peter it's
not so much a book about a television as
it is a history of the 50s as television
portrayed that I wanted to write a
history of the 50s which had been done
many times but it had never been done as
television portrayed that how were
African Americans portrayed on
television what was their role women
religion I got Bishop Sheen had a highly
rated primetime
show which which among other things
vehemently denounced abortion one of the
programs and that was fine
back then so I wanted to write a history
of of that period television just
happened to be the prism Eric burns you
also bring in the intersection of policy
and television and you use Estes
Kefauver as the example what who was he
and what happened Estes Kefauver is the
only member of the House or Senate ever
to win an Emmy one of the most gripping
events in the early days of television
with the what came to be known as there
was an official name that came to be
known as the the Kefauver hearings they
were investigated organized crime and
stores that sold televisions Peter would
have televisions in the window with with
some kind of apparatus a loudspeaker
rigged up with a volume and people would
would not only block the sidewalk but
block the streets to watch them it was
harder for television in the early 50s
America was mesmerised by this look into
organized crime which so many Americans
didn't know existed and these these
these these rough sounding ruthless
names I'm half-italian the half that
isn't Burns and I remember my
grandmother when she saw the when I told
her I saw the Godfather
she said why they got give all those men
Italian names why they got give them all
Italian and I'm thinking back to the
Kefauver hearings and thinking well
grandma we we did it so that's who
Kefauver was he chaired the hearings and
it did lead those hearings did lead
Peter to somewhat of a reduction in
organized crime and to a great deal of
legislation and as I said to an Emmy but
senator Kefauver regretted almost
you write that he almost regretted the
televi the televised hearings he he
regretted them I think largely from a
personal point of view he was a serious
man who because he became a
inadvertently a television star which
was a phrase that didn't even exist then
I think was taken less seriously I think
if you're a member of the Senate you
probably don't want to win an Emmy
now Emmys are for actors he wasn't an
actor he was a man who had a serious
interest in in helping to rid this
country of organized crime or lessen the
impact of it and he thought that the
overwhelming popular he thought there
was such a thing as too much popularity
and that most of it fell on him and
because of that he was not taken
seriously you know it's almost analogous
I think Peter to the the actor who uh
you know plays Robin to Batman and never
gets another role you know how actors
complained that their they had one role
they played it for ten years on
television they were so popular no one
took them for granted in any other way
this is an aside but we have a great
deal of time here a really startling
moment the movie Clute the the Jane
Fonda starred in Donald Sutherland I
think was clue to a private eye there
was an astonishingly tense moment when
Jane Fonda went creeping through a
factory of some sort very dark very
quiet very near the end of the movie the
Dana moi climbed up the stairs and and
she could see a light in her office she
opened the door and who was there but
Jean Stapleton in other words Archie
Bunker's wife in the time between the
movie the movies rapping and the start
of all on the family she had gotten that
role and because of it this incredibly
10
this moment turned out to be a comedy oh
my god there's what was the name eateth
there's a Edith bunker and it completely
ruined the the scene close parentheses
and the beside would Estes Kefauver be
in favor of television in the Senate and
in the House of Representatives today
yes I think so because it would focus on
not one man but it would focus on so
many men and women back then it was men
that it would be more fair to say that
it focused on process than on people and
I think he father would have favored
making the process more clear to
American people back to all the news
that's unfit to print you write about
Russell long in that book Senator
Russell long and his habits do I you do
could you give me a little more of a
hint it's been ten years since I wrote
that what you talk about is it how
journalists this goes back to the sins
of omission and how he spent quite a bit
of time drinking but it was never
reported well that went along thank you
very much I'm sorry that I needed all
that help and I really did write the
book but I generally go from one book to
another rather quickly so I'm being
interviewed about one book and I'm I'm
my mind is totally on another and in
this case quite a few books have
intervened that was an error of course
when sexual peccadilloes were not
peccadilloes is too lighthearted a word
for adultery but let's say when sexual
peccadilloes were not reported and
drinking was something that the you know
maybe maybe the members of the press
corps weren't committing adultery but
they were all drinking so they certainly
weren't on a report on a legislator who
was drinking especially a man as
powerful as long in
since and my friend the columnist Cal
Thomas makes a really good point here
back in those days when when people
members of the House and the Senate
weren't so concerned about campaigning
constantly especially members of the
House who run every two years they
tended to stay in Washington over the
weekend so journalists got to know
legislators legislators got to know each
other and there was less hostility when
it came to compromise legislative
compromise and now you've got so many
legislators so many members of the house
leaving on Thursday night first thing
out Friday morning to campaign coming
back Monday midday and they don't know
they don't have friends among their
fellow legislators and my friend Cal
thinks that for that reason we have the
kind of roadblocks that we do today and
legislatively Eric Byrnes is our guest
this month on in depth he is a
journalist and an author and we're going
to show you some of his books then we're
going to figure out what the connection
between all these books are in just a
minute from our author broadcast blues
was his first book that came out in 1993
the joy of books confessions of a
lifelong reader in 1995 the autograph a
modern fable of a father and daughter
his one novel the spirits of America
social history of alcohol came out in
2004 infamous scribblers the founding
fathers and the rowdy beginnings of
American journalism 2006 the smoke of
the gods the social history of tobacco
came out in 2007 virtue valour and
vanity the founding fathers in the
pursuit of fame also came out in 2007
all the news unfit to print that we've
been talking about 2009 invasion of the
mind Snatchers televisions conquest of
America in the 50s 2010 his most recent
books nineteen twenty the year that made
the deck
rawrr came out last year and the golden
lad the haunting story of Quentin and
Theodore Roosevelt is his latest book
Eric Byrnes you got the colonial area
you've got the turn-of-the-century
you've got the media what's a connection
between all these books they all have
topics that interest me I'm an avid
reader my personal library at home has
about 2,000 volumes in it and I'll be
damned if I can find a connection
between topics but I read in the case of
the most recent book which has the
subtitle the haunting story of Quentin
and Theodore Roosevelt I've read a lot
of biographies of Theodore Roosevelt I
have 14 in fact 14 of those 2000 books
are biographies Theodore Roosevelt and
that every one I came across an incident
that was oh sometimes a footnote
sometimes a sentence a paragraph maybe a
few paragraphs but it struck me as a
fascinating story a fascinating way to
get inside
Roosevelt's mind and nobody did it
now the reason is that Roosevelt
probably had more I think he held more
government positions at various levels
than any other man in our nation's
history and you could write a whole book
about Theodore Roosevelt as the police
commissioner of New York
I think it's been done Doug Brinkley
wrote 900 pages on Theodore Roosevelt as
a conservationist his life is a mural
and I saw something in my reading that
was a small section in that painting and
I thought that if that section were
explained in great detail the right
colors the right shadings that there
would be a story about Theodore
Roosevelt that would would not only be
fascinating but would probably if not
change the minds of
people about Theodore Roosevelt give
people something different to think
about there are some people who don't
know the story and so I'd like to
pretend I'm a suspense novelist who's
not going to blow the ending but I will
tell you the three elements that I saw
in the other books that I thought could
be put into one story in which is what
the golden lad does Theodore Roosevelt
was the most bellicose man who has ever
been in the White House Theodore
Roosevelt was the best father best
parent okay father
because there were I don't know about
mothers in the White House best father
who's ever been in the White House
his son Quentin was his youngest and
favorite those are the three elements
which joined with a few circumstances
that had nothing to do with the
personalities led to this book so in
this case the topic came from my
thinking that something very interesting
had been neglected you also though get
into Roosevelt's relationship with
Woodrow Wilson with William Howard Taft
in this book to set it up well I I had a
very different modus operandi for doing
this book most books about Theodore
Roosevelt and I measured are between one
and a half and two inches thick the ones
that I have I don't know if it's easy
for viewers to tell and these are Peters
notes you can see our diligent he's been
this is not one and a half or two inches
thick the way I wrote this book was to
see how much I could leave out because I
wanted to tell I wanted to concentrate
on the center of the mural not all the
important events on the outside yes I
left in his feelings toward Woodrow
Wilson
all of the major events in his life are
there but in all cases
Quentin's reaction is somehow involved
for instance when he decided not to run
for a second full term he served three
years after McKinley had been
assassinated he won one term from the
electorate he could have run for a
second term he decided not to eventually
much to his sorrow but I wrote about
that what's that have to do with Quentin
well there was an incident in which
Theodore and Quentin were sitting at
watching the parade for Taft and
Quentin's reaction Quentin's sadness to
it was a very important part of my story
when McKinley was assassinated well of
course that has to be in the book but
the main reason that's in the book is
that Quentin had a collection of dolls
of male figures and he cut out little
scraps of black paper
I'm sorry black fabric armbands and put
them around the arms of his his his
figures I guess today we might call them
action figures and when asked why he
said very solemnly he said for President
McKinley so my choice of material tried
to do two things cover everything in his
life that needed to be covered but not
to the extent that that Edmund Morris
did in three volumes about Roosevelt but
enough to make it a tale of Theodore
Roosevelt but to make sure that Quentin
was always edging in did that book
spring from your previous book on 1920
no anyway no and if you're gonna try to
find connections Peter I wish you well
the 20s have always interested me I
think they
interested a lot of people in my reading
it so happened that the not only did the
the decade come up a lot which it always
does if you read American history but
the year came up a lot it was the year
of the first terrorist attack in this
country we talked about homeland
security then we didn't call it that it
was the year of the Ponzi scheme and as
I as I posited in the book I think Ponzi
probably is better known to people
because of Bernie Madoff than he is
because of himself I will try to list
everything that happened in 1920 but
some of what happened in 1920 like the
terrorist detect has repercussions that
went beyond the year the decade and the
century we're dealing with terrorism
today so I found it just a fascinating
year the problem with writing a book
about a year is you have to find a story
you have to find the narrative you can't
just you can't have chapters called
January 1st January 2nd and I I really
embraced that challenge of trying to get
some characters into the book in places
where they wouldn't normally come before
Harding's presidency I was able to say
that in in writing about Main Street
Sinclair Lewis's Main Street that Warren
Harding looked as if he had been a
character from that book it was this
challenging a book as I've ever had the
right because of trying to find a
narrative and of course the narrative is
a little loose but that's what years are
events don't happen to satisfy the needs
of authors which i think is cosmically
unfair but it doesn't happen well you
said that you would didn't want to list
everything that happened in that year
well I made a list of some of the issues
of
in 1920 and gonna read them off and let
you either riff on them compare them to
today whatever you want to do
you've got your leads you've got Marcus
Garvey and race relations
you've got Prohibition Wayne wheeler I
want to talk about Wayne wheeler you've
the women vote universal suffrage the
only year by the way the two amendments
to the Constitution were passed 1920
flight is coming into vogue
you've got prosperity you've got
inequality
you've got terrorism you've got labor
unrest you've got the Carnegie's and the
Rockefellers going on
you've got Harlem and you've got jazz
one of the things that I thought would
annoy the man who did the jacket design
for 1920 of the year that made the
decade roar is that there is a chapter
it's a small chapter but it explains why
the flapper was the most inappropriate
symbol possible for that year and I
would think that if I were an author and
I were you know planning the jacket
design of a book called 1920 that's the
first thing I would think of as it turns
out it wasn't for him and it turned out
not to be a problem
let me tell you something about
prohibition I mean there's an awful lot
to say but you mentioned Wayne wheeler
Wayne wheeler was a mousy little man in
appearance and I think he was called I
don't know if it was the Dynamo I think
something like a dynamo in trousers in
terms of his ability Wayne wheeler
organized the first powerful political
action committee in this country and its
purpose was to make was to create
prohibition there was never a time in
the United States never a time when a
majority of us wanted to make
alcohol illegal never but hmm wheeler
and his people would go to the churches
and talk to the people in charge of the
churches say well you know if we put out
some literature that notes your church
supports alcohol and is not in favor of
getting rid of alcohol it's not going to
look good for your church is it went to
politicians and said if we you know if
we let it be known that the alcohol is a
an important part of your lives
something that you want to have at your
disposal at any time that your
constituents might wonder about you
people should be thinking of the word
bribery in essence that's what he did
and in essence that's what so many
lobbyists do today in one way or another
and because of that he was able to do
one of the most remarkable and
preposterous things that's ever been
done in this country and that is make
these sale manufacture and distribution
of alcoholic beverages illegal drinking
them was legal but the rest of it wasn't
a word were there one percenters
so-called one percenters in the 1920s
what are one percenters the very wealthy
extremely wealthy oh you're talking in
those terms I'm sorry I thought you were
talking about in terms of view of
alcoholic beverages sure I don't know
whether it would have been 1% but my
goodness well a Commodore Vanderbilt was
dead but Carnegie Frick great numbers of
people we don't even know yes there was
there was there was inconceivable wealth
I would guess and it's it's an educated
guess so I think it's worth mentioning
that there was probably a greater
disparity in wealth then than there is
now
was this a prosperous country in your
view from your research it was a
prosperous country that was beginning to
rot from within in 1920
mmm there are a couple of examples of
not stocks that we're doing poorly but
what was it corn rice we I can't
remember one at one of is something
something that a prescient person would
have seen as as a coming negative was
happening in in the grain markets there
there were some clues that a bug some
bugs were crawling up through the the
big bulging barrels of prosperity nobody
saw them hmm nobody wanted to see you
but as early as 1920 somebody could have
seen them and somebody could have warned
the populace which Peter would have paid
no attention all right here's a
connection this is from your book the
spirits of America you write that we
read in our histories that the
Revolutionary War was conceived in the
watering holes of colonial America
but almost as an aside and we never
asked why why it would astonish people
to know how important alcoholic
beverages were in colonial times what
you might have had for bacon sorry for
breakfast this morning
had you and a columnist was a bacon
cooked in rum in most American towns the
bells rang out at 11:00 and for these
were the equivalent of a morning and an
afternoon happy hour
people stopped to drink to drink they
drank alcoholic beverages with every
meal
children were given alcoholic beverages
so as to toughen them
no one knows and and and that makes all
of this suspect that alcoholic beverages
weren't as powerful then as they are now
but no one knows that there's just no
way to tell well you know that there is
no bottle of 1778
Chardonnay around somewhere that we can
open and and and get a true measure of
the alcoholic content but when you
consider what the Founding Fathers
accomplished it's pretty hard to think
of them as doing that all of that while
an eve read but another reason it was
not just the taste not just the for want
of a better word hi there was a strong
belief at the time in the medicinal
value of alcoholic beverages and I think
it came from the notion that other forms
of medicine had powerful tastes to them
alcoholic beverages had powerful taste
to the mint to put it very simply the
thought was that if there was something
wrong in your body and you put enough
rum in your body whatever it was in your
body that wasn't working was going to
get drunk and die
were some of the more famous founding
fathers were they drinkers as well all
of them all Thomas Jefferson wrote the
Declaration of Independence
along with input for many others with a
glass of red wine at his elbow Ben
Franklin wrote a song in praise of
Madeira which was his favorite wine
Washington may have drunk the least but
when he left the White House was it
called the White House then no it wasn't
when he left the president's house he
installed a brewery at Mount Vernon
Alexander Hamilton was an occasional
drinker John Adams a a kept bar in his
attended bar in his father's tavern
Patrick Henry also was a bartender for a
while I don't know who I'm missing him
but I'm not missing a teetotaler back
the spirits of America right that buying
votes with booze during the early years
of the Republic Washington did not
originate the practice but used the
practice I think that's a wonderful
story here's how the the the first
informal very informal political poll
came about one of the ways that you
tried to attract votes was by putting a
bigger VAT or more vats of liquor in
front of a polling place than your
Challenger did he who bought the most
beer bought the most votes and the
practice was to dip a ladle into the VAT
of the person for whom you had voted so
assuming you did that then somebody who
came along let's say at 3:30 4:00
o'clock in the afternoon and looked in
the vats and saw which one had the least
liquor in it you know could go on the
air and say early projections here at
CBS are the George Washington will win
the seat for the Virginia House of
Burgesses because he only has 7 inches
left in his bare
where as this competitor has 12 inches
Washington was Washington lost his first
attempt to get a seat in the Virginia
House of Burgesses and he went to the
equivalent of his campaign manager the
second time around and said and this is
almost a quote do not spend with two
sparing a hand
well it's mentioned in the in in the
book how much Washington spent but hard
cider was a very popular drink then rum
different kinds of wine whiskey
Washington was elected the second time
Eric Byrnes was there any connection
between tainted water and the use of
alcoholic beverages yes yes coffee was
not drunk for several reasons it was
hard to get the beans but you mixed the
beans once they were in the proper form
with water same problem with tea
although tea also had an image problem
because the British drank tea so we
didn't want to do that alcoholic
beverages were and that's an astute
question perceived as not only the most
beneficial for your health because they
killed what was going on inside of you
that should have been killed but they
were also the safest to drink how
important was tobacco in the colonial
era it was more important in the
pre-columbian era and this is what
fascinates me a lot of similarities
between booze and alcohol because both
started out as parts of religious
practices now if you drink a certain
amount you will not feel the same way
you feel if you hadn't drunk that amount
you'll be a little tipsy a little high
and and and the the Native American
tribes felt that that state whatever you
want to call it was a religious state
and made them more susceptible to be
able to communicate
with the gods well with regard to
tobacco it was even more interesting
tobacco was tobacco smoke was thought to
be a medicine all right let me get this
out of the way now
let me apologize first for this but it's
true in the 17th century in Paris there
was a doctor who cured women do you
remember this is that why you're sitting
there apprehensively who cured women who
were hysterical by blowing tobacco smoke
in to their vaginas my comment after
that was this seems more likely to cause
hysteria than to cure it but the notion
of tobacco smoke being a cure for
diseases lasted centuries tobacco leaves
back to pre-columbian times and no more
reference to female organs of any sort
or male the the the primary use of them
was to smoke at the temple and pray as
you smoked and what would happen is that
your prayers would be transmitted by the
smoke up to celestial realms
now tobacco smoke doesn't go up very
high and my first thought was well the
Native Americans must have been very
disappointed to see their prayers
disappear so quickly ah but they were
quite adaptive in their thinking and
what they came to decide was that
invisible heavenly hands had reached
down taken the prayers and now they were
in heaven getting due consideration
so both tobacco and alcohol went from
roughly speaking from being artifacts of
religious practice to medicinal
ingredients to ingredients of great
or substances of great controversy and
in one case two substances tobacco that
are virtually banned everywhere and
again I'm just what drew you to the
history of tobacco I mean there had to
be some spark that got you into that
somebody said to me my father was an
alcoholic I mean nobody told me that my
father was an alcoholic I knew that I
could have phrased that a little better
my father was an alcoholic who smoked
four packs of cigarettes a day at his
peak and someone said to me someone was
asking me the same question you did and
I said I you know I I read history and I
thought these you know the incident
about prayers being transmitted by smoke
and how the founding fathers drank
we're just inherently interesting but
somebody said to me isn't it interesting
that your father was an abuser of these
two ingredients but I never knew what to
make of that Peter because if you've
read those two books you know that there
are no that they don't preach their
histories people often ask me well when
you start a history do you have to have
a point of view and my answer is if you
start writing a history with a point of
view then I don't want to read that book
you know I don't care who you are if I
know you're a brilliantly literate
Republican I don't want to read a
history by you or a brilliantly literate
Democrat I don't want to read your work
I don't want to read an authorized
biography that tells me that the truth
may have worked its way in somehow but
in terms of alcohol and and tobacco
I've just never been able to decide
whether my father had anything to do
with it simply because
if he had wouldn't I have here I am
psychoanalyzing myself wouldn't I have
wanted to preach in at least one
paragraph wouldn't I have wanted to I
could attribute it to someone else you
know I can say today there are numerous
people there statistics that show that
overuse of alcohol leads to a
dissolution of one out of every four
marriages or something like that there's
nothing there's nothing like that in the
book it's a matter of fact I I'm not
very fond of the present I I mean I'm
happy to be here today but I don't I try
not to get too close to the present in
my books in the smoke of the gods one
has to go to 1964 that was the Surgeon
General's major report that changed
everything but I I I like to I like to
stay away from the present Eric Byrnes
how old was your father when he died I
didn't know him well I think he was in
his late 70s or early 80s which means
that he could have been 130 135 if he
would have taken care of himself he was
a slender man a good athlete as a young
man not just a drunk but an abusive
drunk where were you raised I was raised
in what started out as a healthy steel
town 15 miles from Pittsburgh by the
time I went to college it was a dying
steel town and the last few times I've
been there is a dead steel town the
ghost towns of America are the towns
that used to produce steel Pittsburgh is
a big beautiful wonderful thriving place
but the small towns that were built on
the river Ambridge named after the
American Bridge Company a subsidiary of
you a steel the town I grew up in 15
miles up the ohio from pittsburgh those
little towns
Beaver Falls Aliquippa they're ghost
towns they are remarkable sites the last
time I was in the area I asked a friend
of mine to walk through he had been the
chief of police to walk through Ambridge
with me I wanted to see it it wasn't
that big and so I know firsthand what a
dead community is and I thought in fact
that I would like to write about that
and may someday what do you remember
about the steel and the importance of
steel tear to remember the smell I
remember black sugar you don't know that
term do you black sugar was the name for
the granules that came out of the
smokestacks and were so insidious that
if you closed all the windows in your
house and closed all the doors there
would be black sugar on your kitchen
table a little bit if you washed your
car left it out in the driveway three or
four hours later you could write your
name on the hood Iran would have loved
Ambridge in those days the economic
health was astonishing there is no more
black sugar and there is no more
employment our guest this month on in
depth is author journalist Eric Byrnes
we're going to put the phone numbers up
on the screen if you'd like to dial in
participate in our conversation and if
you've been listening you can see that
there's a lot of topics that we have
covered already trying to make
connections between all these topics
2:02 is the area code 7 4 8 8200 if you
live in the east and central time zone
seven four eight eight two zero one for
those of you out in the mountain and
Pacific time zones now if you can't get
through on the phone line still want to
make a comment you can do so via social
media first of all you can go to our
Facebook page facebook.com slash book TV
you'll see some video of mr. Byrnes post
right up at the top and you can make a
comment right under that you could also
send us an email to book TV at c-span
dot o-r-g you can send a tweet at book
TV and finally if you just want to send
a text message now this is not for phone
calls but this is just for text messages
to zero to seven one seven nine six
eight four when did you leave Ambridge
and why to go to college and I never
went back and I think the wise is fairly
obvious how'd you get into this business
I always wanted to write my first goal
was to write for The New Yorker in the
30s which shows that I had a certain
problem with chronology my second goal
was to write for Look magazine to have
my own column in Look magazine and I
ended up at NBC sharing an office with
Betty Rowling who had a column in Look
magazine and sharing a slot on the Today
Show said not sharing one I didn't sit
in his lap next to gene Shalit who was
the movie reviewer for look I wrote
maybe five novels that were not
published mmm and decided perhaps I
should write nonfiction and went back to
the old maxim now write about what you
know about and that's how Broadway
broadcast Blues came about but there was
never any doubt in my mind that I wanted
to do this I got into television news
because I as a young man of not
significant intellectual breadth I
didn't know what to write about so I
thought if I led the what I thought was
the exciting life of a television
journalist I would a be writing albeit
two minutes stories that fluttered
through the ether and went away and I
didn't want to do that I wanted
Peter's lens someday to be able to have
what I wrote on a table in in front of
me but eventually broadcast Blues came
about and writing about books after that
seemed natural and television always
came fairly easily to me so there was
almost always time in the day to write
and now that's what I do
full-time the golden lad is just out the
next book about which I don't want to
talk is finished I'm working on the one
after that
what's the topic of the next book that's
what I don't want to talk about but you
made your living though your day-to-day
living in broadcast television I did
yeah as someone once said I made a great
deal of money in a little bit of time on
television and a little bit of money
with a great deal of time writing books
is this profitable can be I didn't lose
money on any of these but something that
I'm I'm particularly proud of in terms
of self analysis is are you holding the
joy of books in your hand in the joy of
books there's it's not a whole chapter
but there's a section about why writers
write and my conclusion was that at
least for me the answer is power I write
because as a fairly typical person I
don't have much power I don't know how
much power
Donald Trump has ultimately he has many
people to whom he has to answer in his
business
the President of the United States has a
great many people to whom he has to
answer unless he goes you know behind a
back door and most of us lack for power
but what I can do and of course a
novelist has more power than I do
because a novelist can create a world
but what I can do is with the world
already created I have the power to
decide what it meant I have the power to
organize the events in such a way that I
can make them clearer that I can
eliminate errors if I have seen errors
that I can entertain with those events
I'm very conscious of trying whenever
it's possible and it's very often
possible to have to be a little witty I
feel strange saying that but to be a
little witty when I can in a book what
I'm sitting there writing my power is
complete
I'm dictatorial over the computer screen
and then you know a voice calls down
would you get up here and set the table
please and I've lost my dictatorial
power immediately from the joy of books
I have never been inspired by another
author what has inspired me is the
constant artistic struggle to put the
English language to its best possible
use in the occasional feeling that I
have done so at those moments I feel
like a painter who has gotten all his
colors right his shadings and use of
light just so and his figures composed
with a geometric precision I have always
wanted to create art as much as relay
information were you able to relay
information via television yeah but
that's all I was able to do I mean a
television reporter who creates art is
not
serving journalism because journalism is
a straightforward presentation of the
facts now if you have a beat like
Charles crawls you know and like mine I
was NBC decided to to try to copy what
Kuralt did and they created a segment
called cross country for the Today Show
and a gentleman named Jack Perkins and I
were that were the two correspondents
for that and I suppose you could make a
case for saying that was art of a very
low grade and I don't know if art is art
if it's on television I guess it is but
I just don't like the way it flutters
away again I I want the I I want the
satisfaction of knowing that it's going
to stay there that it can be read by
others that it can be known by others at
other times and relaying information
just wasn't enough for me I wanted to do
something that I thought was more
creative than that I left NBC to do a
project at PBS which would have
accomplished that however PBS ran out of
money partway through but the series
which I was going to do was three hours
on the history of smoking three hours on
the history of drinking it's quite a few
years later I found my notes and I had
two books waiting to be written and then
I got back into my dictatorial mode the
first line in the joy of books is that
the book Peter Pan was the most
important book in your childhood
and as an adult it really troubled me
yeah I'm old enough even though I look
dashingly young I'm old enough to
remember Mary Martin as Peter Pan and I
just love the notion of a place you
could escape to like Neverland love the
notion of being able to fly and then as
a parent I got to think of Peter Pan as
insidious' to do was take the darling
that was the name of the family the
darling children three children away
from their parents well I was a parent
then with kids and with very strong
feelings which I still maintained for my
two children and I thought Peter Pan if
he had his way would take my children to
a place that I could never find so I've
changed my opinion of Peter well and
we'll go through this a little bit later
but you've also got a list of some of
the most influential books for you both
fiction and nonfiction and some of the
books that have been consistently banned
over the years that you write about
attending a book banning or a book
burning I think it was yeah that was a
story for NBC and I really don't
remember much about it now I know it
wasn't one book it was a town that was
cleaning out books that were deemed
inappropriate for students the only ones
that I remember were Tom Sawyer and
Huckleberry Finn maybe Lord of the Flies
certainly oh why am i drawing a blank JD
Salinger come on tell me I catch her in
the rock that's her in there I yeah in
other words classics classic literature
tended to be and I guess we don't have
book burnings anymore so I'll use the
past tense
tended to be the victims of book
burnings more than just average novels
what do you think when you hear Catcher
in the Rye sold about 45 million copies
since it was written I don't get it
one of the things that I say in the joy
of books is that over the years it looks
as if books are just sitting inert on
our shelves but they're not within the
covers there's a great deal of change
going on for instance Holden Caulfield
when I was in my 20s Holden Caulfield
was a really admirable figure who
wouldn't put up with any phone enos in
the adult world and and just wasn't
going to stand for that and was going to
do what he thought he should do and not
be under the sway of foolish adult
priorities well I'm a lot older than 20
now and I think Holden cofee Halton
coalfield has changed immensely I think
he's a spoiled whiny brat who didn't
appreciate what was done for and I think
that can be said about a lot of other
people too Eric Byrnes is our guest and
now it's your turn we've talked for an
hour Clare in Huntington Station New
York you're on book TV good afternoon
good afternoon thank you very much for
taking my call I consider watching this
show all the time as additional college
education it is so informative I really
enjoy it I'd like to ask mr. burns about
the water crisis that's going on in
Flint Michigan now he's mentioned some
things that I think relate to it here he
raised the question about water and
alcohol and he also mentioned Pittsburgh
and what's going on there I don't feel
that this water crisis is being
adequately reported on I feel that it
should be the number one story it should
be reported on every day I'm trying to
hearing about what Donald Trump thinks
if Ted Cruz and Ted Cruz thinks as
Donald Trump how do you feel
this whole thing I feel it a hundred
thousand people have been poisoned in
American city and it's just not being
talked about that right let's get let's
see if Eric burns wants to opine on that
I don't think I have anything
constructive to say I saw a lengthy
piece done either on 60 minutes or I
can't keep them straight 2020 Dateline a
major piece done on this I'm not
particularly qualified to make a
judgement on whether it's being covered
enough III can say Claire I'm sorry III
realize that's a disappointing answer
for you but I don't follow journalism to
the extent that I used to but I
certainly agree with you that the story
itself is is a major story and deserves
a great deal of of not just coverage but
of an investigative work which is to say
the careful looking into the causes of
this and how the causes can be prevented
Edie Newman remember at Newman from at
BC NBC a colleague of mine at Newman
said well what we need here is some good
journalism a good investigative
journalism or as we used to call it
journalism well take take Clare's
comments and take it back to your
experience at NBC were these same
discussions arguments controversies held
back then which is we need to give more
time to this story less time to two
story X always every day there were two
or three meetings involving the anchor
the executive producer a few other
people yes I would get phone calls maybe
at four o'clock let's say two o'clock I
was told I had a minute 45 started
editing I later I get a call saying no
you got to make it a minute 20 I can't
do that because of the way I've
constructed it you've got to make it a
minute 20 so yes by and large network
news is peopled
by extremely conscientious men and women
who under very difficult circumstances I
think do the best they can
minute 20 on network news that pretty
precious define precious was that a good
amount of time no not for anything and
it was pretty short
of course I worked at NBC a long time
ago but I my pieces for NBC Nightly News
when John Chancellor was the anchor were
between a minute and a half and two
minutes I would say
Dave's calling in from Glenn Shaw
Pennsylvania hi Dave hi I love the show
I get a lot of ideas for books that I
read for the show my question for mr.
burns he talked about being from a small
community ban River from Pittsburgh I
live in a community north of Pittsburgh
Pittsburgh seems to it were bonded from
the steel disasters and has become the
tech the way into the tech stuff with
Google and Facebook now opening up
places near Carnegie Mellon does he have
any ideas or theories as to why some of
those other communities such as Ambridge
and Aliquippa and a lot of those old
steel towns haven't been able to rebound
and become productive communities thank
you very much I think one of the main
reasons Dave his size Pittsburgh always
had the size to provide the facilities
that would draw companies there it had
the skyscrapers u.s. steel never left
even when it had to turn its its
manufacturing emphasis to other goods
and services
Pittsburgh never relied entirely on one
industry it was a big city no big cities
depend entirely on one industry the
small towns however did and when that
industry went away the
swat away with them Eric burns I think
it was in 1920 that you write that there
were like 3,600 labor strikes in that
one year alone just some phenomenal
number what was going on what was going
on is that the the picture we have 1920s
being a carefree time is totally
incorrect what was going on was that the
so-called robber barons were were
treating their workers as if they were
prisoners of war
virtually the hours that they worked the
days that they worked the salaries if
you can call them that the pocket change
that they were given for their labors
just appalling and a good indication of
what life was like for the average man
and and a woman what women did a lot of
work you know with clothing the Triangle
Shirtwaist fire killed nothing but girls
young women most young women didn't have
short skirts with fringes on the bottom
and they didn't dance on tables and
nightclubs that was just a few you asked
me a while ago about journalism being
the first draft of history
well journalism emphasized always the
sensationalistic well which was a more
sensational story these women dancing on
tables or women sewing buttons on
callers on shirt shirt waists the women
dancing on tables journalism was the
first draft of history so history
adopted the flapper history was wrong
Danah Oakland California good afternoon
you're on book TV with Eric Byrnes well
thank you I'm enjoying the show
immensely myself and thank you mr. burns
and these fan in general I want to ask
you mr. burns about
salsa note that you made yourself in
regards to your family life as a child
where you mentioned that your alcoholic
dad was also abusive I want to thank you
for your honesty you're the opposite of
your omission you put it in there and
I'd like to ask how that affected your
mother yourself your childhood your
siblings if you have some and your
trajectory and if you have any other
insights on how people could heal as an
adult of an abusive alcoholic Danna why
do you ask that question I think that it
is a root cause of a lot of continuing
problems in our world and unless you dig
out those roots the weeds will grow back
is that something that you're familiar
with yes
well let me say that and I said earlier
that I thought someone would find one of
my answers unsatisfactory Danna you
certainly will that's not anything I
want to talk about and I don't think
it's appropriate to this program I will
say one thing that perhaps I felt all
children feel somewhat powerless even in
the best of families they can't help
their little decisions have to be made
for them I might because of my father
have felt a little less powerless than
the average child and therefore wanted
more than the average child to become
powerful through writing but as far as
how that affected me in personal ways I
don't think that's our topic here today
this text message for you Eric burns
what contributed on the whole to your
maintaining objectivity given ever
increasing inclinations to the contrary
we see today
you know why that's hard to answer Peter
it's because it's so obvious I I don't I
mean that's what a historian is supposed
to do tell the truth the book about
tobacco the smoke of the gods if you
tell the truth about tobacco you write
on the anti tobacco book but that's
because you're telling the truth tobacco
is is is a very harmful substance but I
don't think it's hard to be objective
maybe it's because there aren't subjects
I don't write about subjects that I have
a deep personal connection with well
even when I did when I wrote about
alcohol I I just thought there was a
great deal of interest there and I never
thought really of my father so I'm happy
to say and I think this speaks well of
me that objectivity is simply I just
never thought of anything else Michaels
in Uniontown Pennsylvania hi Michael
yes sir are you doing how are you no
one's talked to mr. down there
I worked it I worked at claritin work
I'm from Uniontown right down here
between Morgantown and Fitchburg I'm
sure you know where that's at and I got
that job err in 1974 and everybody
everybody that lived in Carden worked at
Curtin you know we had man we had you
know there was just you can't find a
parking place in the morning to go to
work and it would I don't know there's a
lot of talk about August you know the
air and all this stuff but I my thing
was we all had at that time in 74 we had
some good jobs you know I mean when I
got my when I got that job I come right
out of high school
I had first paycheck I took her my dad
told me he was a Marine for 23 years and
he told me the first thing he said to me
was don't you quit this job what we had
Blue Cross Blue Shield I go to dinner so
I could go to the dock you could do all
that stuff and you know I don't know it
seems like the world changes you know we
used to come out of there and there was
a book you know every gate at claritin
there was a bar at we're going to have a
couple beers and and go home and it just
seemed like I don't know yeah you know
just you had the Steelers you know these
guys if you worked on a Sunday these
guys that bring big pots of pollute keys
and all that stuff when yeah I
understand the point that you're making
and Peter I know you were just about to
do this but I want to follow up and ask
him but it doesn't have anything to do
with what we're right I think it's he's
talking about a past Society and Michael
do you do you miss that life oh I missed
that life greatly we didn't you know we
you know I don't know everybody now is
you know everybody's all know I and I
understand about the air and there's not
you know but you know Pittsburgh back
then and you know in the 1770s don't
that was a that was just the bleh
you know it was just steel time and I'm
not saying we don't need to clean up the
air or nothing like that but it's just
the idea that we all went to work
everybody worked you know I get like I
said claritin yeah yeah Michael I think
we do get the idea Eric burns anything
you want to comment on there no no
that's something I was discussing in a
personal vein not in the vein of
something I wrote and I I know I have no
comment to make other than what I did
make already text message how would you
describe today's media both in print and
TV and the and the u.s. educational
system oh come on
that's just much too broad do you have
any comments you'd like to make on that
or any opining you'd like to do well how
did it begin today's media today's media
me yeah here's here's my point on who
I'm really gonna alienate some viewers
here here's my point on the media
it's a grammatical point media is a
plural noun not a singular noun the
singular is medium when you talk about
media you're talking about dozens and
dozens and dozens of different outlets I
can't possibly comment on every one of
them except to say I think there are too
many and most of them aren't trustworthy
the educational system it doesn't work I
don't know how to fix it Michael Port
Chester New York you're on with author
Eric Byrnes
hi mr. burns I am going to probably have
to light up my Kindle and buy some of
your books one of the things I wanted to
maybe circle back to is your book on TV
and how it affected I'm a first
generation American Italian if you wish
and how it helped me acculturate and
develop my language in terms of English
in the outside world because at you know
by the time I reach the university age I
was lucky enough to get a good education
and be one of two to the first people to
graduate from college so in a way the TV
and its language and its presentation of
good and evil helped my development well
it's it's a it's a good point about the
language and it's a very common point
and just think of what a great teacher
television was even with the worst of
programs because the the Ru dad's off
working your mother has a lot to do at
home she's preparing dinner something
like
that she might wish she had time to work
with you on your language but she
doesn't but she doesn't have to
you can sit and and watch television and
in terms of almost the second thing he
said developing values it helped develop
his values yes some of his values that's
probably a fair thing to say about
television in its earliest days because
all of the all of the sitcoms had
families that were ridiculously what I
want to say let ridiculously wholesome
lives and that's a great thing I wish my
family could have been Ozzie and Harriet
or the Andersons on father knows best I
don't look at those shows and laugh and
say how unrealistic they are I look at
life today and say it's too bad that
life isn't closer to making those
programs realistic ken q BIA texts in I
went to Ambridge high school and
remember Eric playing basketball as his
father was my teacher
what he says is on the mark this can Q
BIA that name ring a bell to you know
and Ken I'm sorry that it doesn't
memories of my playing basketball
require a great deal of thought because
I didn't get into too many games thank
you for your call and and for your
compliment my dad was a much beloved
math teacher actually at Ambridge high
because he was sober during the day he
got up in the morning and he went to
school and didn't start drinking till
after school and that's the end I'd like
that to be anybody else who has a call
about my father did hang up that's
enough about my father well let's try it
on sequitur here from virtue valor and
vanity you write that the founding
fathers sought a kind of Fame we
do not know today they sought it through
behavior seldom exhibited any more and
even less often brought to public
attention by media outlets attracted to
freakishness and violence borer than
Civic and affection
could you please expand on that
statement that guy can write
occasionally that's a wonderful point
and I'm glad you brought that up as a
matter of fact I had this is the only
book I ever had arguments about with the
publisher I wanted the title of that
book to be the founding fathers in the
pursuit of Fame and I was lucky to get
it to be the subtitle because I thought
the notion we'll wait a minute the
founding fathers wanted to be famous
that's a fascinating idea to me
as a matter of fact the book I'm working
on now that I'm not discussing with you
has talks about that because it's
relative to the main theme their belief
was that Fame can only accrue to you if
you are known for work that advanced the
public good that's the only way in those
days you weren't a famous singer you
weren't a famous actor you weren't a
famous anything you could be notorious
which a lot of people think is a synonym
for faith here's a for fame another
grammar lesson it is in fact the
opposite but that they were they were it
was such in in in the degradation of
fame and we've gotten to a point now
which fame is so degraded that you know
you have I mean what's a Kardashian what
is a Kardashian other than a famous
person the founding fathers worked hard
to deserve Fame and they john adams more
than any person any other founders
believed that he would not be regarded
by posterity with sufficient
appreciation for what he had done ie he
would not be famous enough
what did he do about it he kept working
harder on governmental documents he
became the president of the United
States that's how you achieved fame
would they appreciate do you think all
the monuments streets towns etc named
after them yes especially Ben Franklin
he was so open about it he said I
deserve to be famous look at all the
things I've done can we argue with him
Patrick
Pacifica California you are on book TV
our author is Eric Byrnes Oh
mr. Bern is really great interview I was
so impressed when the you're your host
to ask you a question about your book
and you hadn't had this reflexive moment
they were honest enough to say nothing
about the question instead of making
something up you instantly became my
hero not mine you're such a really
compelling historian you've just been so
many places we're about the same age
actually I'm just a recently retired
mathematics teacher myself and but I
wanted to ask you about the recently
Peter Dale Scott put something out on
about the behind the North Korean new
crisis so he was going over you know
what's transpired since you know 53 and
how many opportunities from this to you
know make some negotiation you know with
them and so I don't know if you remember
the mouse that roared and I mean even
when I wrote it read it at 11:00 there
was the accompanying discussion in
middle school was about how the Duchy of
grand Fenwick was modeled after North
Korea and now we had this petulant idiot
child or you know supreme leader Kim
Jong Un's like he's now he's like the
Duchess Gloriana ruler grand Fenwick and
I was got his own Q bomb and now he's
got a delivery
and all he wants to give some attention
so I was wondering if we could just
maybe sing you know ambassador Dennis
Rodman cider him and negotiate an end to
the 70 year at Bardot and maybe throw in
a NBA franchise or something like that
you know I mean if you think this is
crazy comparing this to u.s. foreign
policy toward Priya's incident before I
just wanted to ask you if you could had
any comments about the the lunacy of US
relations via and any solutions that you
see analyzing dennis rodman sounds as
good as anything else to me Eric burns
in your study writing of history do you
see connections to today oh sure sure
history is believed to be cyclical the
United States the model for the country
that became the United States was the
Roman Republic Cicero who was like Ben
Franklin and in that he craved fame
Cicero was the hero of all the founding
fathers because Cicero was the
philosophical guiding light behind the
Roman Republic which in effect became
the United States and connections just
go on endlessly Peter yes as a matter of
fact that's one of the fascinations of
studying it there there two things that
appeal to me about history the first is
you can learn so much about the roots
you can't understand the president
without something one of the caller's
you use the word roots you can't fully
understand the present without knowing
the past so the past helps you know the
present the second appeal of history to
me is the past gets you the hell away
from the present and that's appealing to
me too
during our political coverage of the
last couple of weeks we've heard from
several viewers that they're looking at
Donald Trump and Bernie Sanders
as potential to support those two um
when you go back in history and look at
some of the politicians and some of the
leaders some of the standouts do you see
a Bernie Sanders or a Donald Trump in
the mix back there well if so they were
regarded as so freakishly
inconsequential that they are not in the
history books so no I don't see one
that's not to say there weren't people
who wanted to be president who were
Bernie Sanders ish and Donald Trump ish
but there was there certainly it never
been candidates the quality you'll
forgive my use of the word quality and
no one I mean of the candidates we have
today for presidency what was Woodrow
Wilson's reputation as he left the oval
office in 1921 well as you know he was
paralyzed it had a stroke a couple of
years earlier and one of the chapters in
1920 is about America's first female
president who was mrs. Woodrow Wilson
and for a year she was the president of
the United States because her husband
her husband was not functioning because
of the stroke he had and there was no
provision in the Constitution for what
to do about a case like that when Wilson
left the White House his reputation was
severely damaged because he had staked
it on the League of Nations as a matter
of fact most people believe that it was
the League of Nations that gave him the
stroke ie he worked so hard
traveled so far and made so many trips
around the country after the Senate had
voted the League of Nations down they
voted it down twice they voted it down
the first time and Wilson said okay I'm
going to the Pacific Northwest to talk
to people and it was on that Trek that
he had his stroke it actually wasn't a
stroke but it was
close enough to that I don't know the
precise medical term to use the word so
there were two primary factors when
Wilson left audience
I'm sorry left the occupation of White
House sympathy for the man and a lack of
respect for the politician how reported
was his health and you can look at FDR
and how reported his health was as well
but how reported was Wilson's health
I've read let me just say
parenthetically that of 35,000
photographs that remain of Franklin
Delano Roosevelt to show him with braces
or any kind of assistance for walking it
was about Woodrow Wilson how reported
was it was his condition that was a time
when there were newspapers didn't have
bureaus in Washington the way they do
now of course there was no television it
was not known by the general public I
would say it was not known at all it
certainly was not known well it was
known by foreign leaders the ambassador
to France reported back to one of his
superiors that he had just had a
conference with Mademoiselle president
so those people who who had dealings
with the government knew but in terms of
somebody who lived in Kansas and was
depending on maybe a brief wire service
report for his or her knowledge of what
was going on in Washington was unlikely
to know Kip Wexford Pennsylvania please
go ahead with your question or comment
for Eric Byrnes hired haven't talked to
you for about five years I wait a minute
tip tip Jones yes
hello Kip how are you hey it's ironic
that that fellow from the
it's called ask about the basketball
question because my question was did you
ever consider writing a historians
perspective of the little engine that
could basketball team at Westminster
that won the national title I know that
buzz had a book about it but did you
ever think about writing about it from
the historians perspective yep what's
your connection with Eric Byrnes how do
you know Eric and I went to college
together thank you sir and it was
Westminster which had a championship
small college basketball team and the
answer is no Kip I never did it never
occurred to me that there was a
particularly interesting angle perhaps
if I'd known the players better I would
have seen that angle but I never saw it
I think it's hard to write about sports
in addition without avoiding cliches and
you'll appreciate this Peter I avoid
cliches like the plague
well Eric Byrnes
we've had several Pennsylvania calls so
I think it's time to introduce a little
bit of video to this program and this is
from WQ e D the winner is Craig
Highberger he goes to Mount Lebanon High
School he's 17 years old and will be
graduating this year and will be
stepping up on the secular I assume no
let's bring Craig over right now why did
you personally want to make a movie that
made a statement about drugs what
personal experience of yours is there in
the movie oh it was just the overall
feeling of school and the futility was
trying to communicate you know in the
classroom which is a difficult thing I
have not lived in high school in most
classes it definitely is maybe we should
say that it's not just Mount Lebanon oh
yeah that was March 5th 1971 which one
of those was I yeah you were not the
blonde or the black woman okay so I was
the one with the longer yeah longer hair
right well I sounded
relatively intelligent don't you think
what was that show we were watching it
was called lifestyle it was on the PBS
station in Pittsburgh the BQE D Studio B
WQED Studio a was mr. Rogers
neighborhood and my first mentor in
television was Fred Rogers
who I said on Fox when he died that I
didn't think there had ever been a
person who used television for better
ends than Fred Rogers and I believe that
strongly I was I was a friend of his and
I was sorry to see him go and an
interesting little aside is that the the
stage manager on that show was a guy
named Michael Douglas not the Michael
Douglas but Michael Douglas went out to
Hollywood to try to make it as an actor
and he was told when he went to sign up
with the Union the d/deaf changed his
name because they're already wasn't Mike
Douglas so he said for some reason he
thought of Buster Keaton he said okay
Michael Keaton and it was that Michael
Keaton what was Fred Rogers like off as
a set and without the sweater the same
there are two people in my life I've met
who were exactly the same on the air as
off Fred Rogers and Bill O'Reilly don't
ask well I could come to a quote if
you'd like me to if you're gonna open up
that door that may I go back and close
it you can close it yeah let's close it
Fred was Fred was the same man Fred was
the same man
Gordon's in Roanoke Virginia hi Gordon
hi thanks for taking my call my wife and
I are very regular read viewers of book
TV and we recommend it to all our
friends and everything and I think I
think book TV is just wonderful
well mr. Byrnes you're a little bit
younger and I am I'm 80 I was interested
in your book in 1920 I'll have to get it
my parents were both 19 years old in
1920 and I can't picture them as
flappers or anything but my question is
it's I'm an engineer and it's sort of an
engineering question you've talked about
how the media popularizes things and
reports things and so forth where do you
get your information about that you
report about history of 1920 I get some
of it I start out by getting it from the
books that I've read information that I
know I can trust because one of one of
the dicta of journalism is that you get
multiple sources and so same thing
writing history if several books go
along with it that's the same thing as
having several sources because if the
history goes back far enough obviously
you can't talk to the people but then
you go to what are called the primary
sources for instance my book current
book the the golden lad the haunting
story of Theodore and Quentin Roosevelt
Quentin and Theodore Roosevelt I went to
Sagamore Hill the Roosevelt residence
and was the the first historian I think
because there was so much dust literally
so much dust on the box that the the
curator who's showing me through said I
don't think this box has ever been
opened it was a letters between Theodore
and his children which did not really
interest most historians because
Theodore did so many more important
things on a political basis the golden
lad I think of as more of a parental
book than a political book but I got my
information and I got my feelings for
what kind of people Quentin and Theodore
were because I read every letter that
passed between them
and that's what you do if it's possible
you you you get a kind of outline from
popular sources and then you start
checking and filling in the holes with
the primary sources this tweet for you
did you admire edward armor oh and if so
why no because I was too young as a
journalist I was taught to admire Edward
armor oh and star read nah no reason not
to but I was boy it's just what a
pleasure it is these days to be able to
say that I'm too young for something I
was a little too young for Murrow and so
like most people my feelings about him
are based on reputation as opposed to
any knowledge from working with him
working with his co-workers anything
like that
2:02 is the area code for all of our
numbers if you want to dial in and talk
with author Eric Byrnes we've covered a
lot of topics so far we've got a little
over an hour to go 7 for 8 8200 for
those in the east and central time zone
7 for 8 8 2 0 1 if you live in the
mountain in Pacific time zones now if
you want to send a text you can send a
text as well this is not for phone calls
this is for texting and we've read
several texts so far today 2 0 to 7 1 7
9 6 8 4 and that's for text messages a
couple other ways to get through on
social media Facebook comm slash book TV
you can leave a comment there or you can
email us at book TV at c-span org and
finally you can send a tweet at book TV
is our Twitter handle well every month
that we have an author on in depth we
ask him or her to talk about some of
their influences some of the books they
have been reading or are reading here
are some of Eric Byrnes answers
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
Eric Burns who is JC furnace or for
Nast's he lists him as one of the
authors that you like he's my brother he
is Joseph Chamberlain furnace or furnace
I'm so embarrassed to say that my
favorite historian is he he's written
some epic histories by epic I mean seven
eight nine hundred pages and he is my
favorite historian because he has
covered so much ground and he has a
sense of humor I don't know why
historians have no senses of humor I'm
not talking about jokes I'm talking
about saying things in a in a witty
manner when it's appropriate and he does
it better than anyone but I've never
heard his name mentioned never I've
never heard his name mentioned so I
don't know if he spurned us or for an
ass and you and I were just is he a
contemporary no he wrote his memoirs in
1983 I happen to be reading them now
because I just found them and died in
1989 in the joy of books you've got
lists of some of the books that have
made a difference for you or that you
felt influenced you and one of the books
you list is a book called broadcast
blues dispatches from the 20-year war
between a television reporter and his
medium it was a book we were unable to
find it's written by Eric Byrnes
I remember that book even though you
were unable to find it and it was the it
was let me just say that it was the
source of the of the eye I've done very
well you know I'm happy to say this this
is this is humility speaking not
braggadocio I'm happy to say that I've
done well over the years with critics
but when the New York Times Book Review
did broadcast blues
what I wrote about was some of the
problems of that I thought the
journalism business had this was 35
years ago that book now is so quaint I I
recommend it to all of you because
because they'll tell you about a world
of journalism that doesn't exist anymore
what was wrong then has been superseded
greatly now but what I did in the book
Peter was I used myself I talked it was
a it was a cross between a memoir and a
book of journalistic criticism and I
used myself for the criticism I
mentioned my name I used the
first-person pronouns several times I
talked about having gotten stuck
interviewing a really foul-mouthed
guy and how we could because we got sent
all the way from Chicago to the Bayou to
do it how we could falsify the story it
was feature and and still use little
sound bites from him when he didn't say
the things he was saying and there were
a couple of other examples too of things
that I that I did that weren't as
ethical as they should have been nothing
compared to what's happened since the
the dolt ish woman who reviewed the book
for the New York Times said mr. burns
gives a good portrait of some of the
problems of television is but what he
doesn't seem to realize is that he is
guilty of these sins just as much as
anyone else it was the point of the book
that I was guilty of the sins as much as
anyone else and this person says but
what mr. burns doesn't seem to realize I
don't know who the person was but that's
the dumbest review I've ever come across
well some of the praise for your 2015
book nineteen twenty the year make that
made the decade roar New York Times Book
Review called it lively burns
convincingly dispels
number of popular beliefs you have
praise from the Washington Post
Publishers Weekly Kirkus The Washington
Times book list says entertaining and
highly readable this text message came
in for you what effect did marcus garvey
have on race relations in 1920 first of
all who is marcus garvey let me also say
immodestly the Kirkus which is one of
two principal organs in the publishing
industry that that publishes reviews of
books in advance of their book
publications so that you know the
bookstores know what to order things
like that named it one of the best books
of 2015 are now back to humility or at
least neutrality marcus garvey was one
of the leaders of one of the
african-american leaders of 1920 his
movement was to have african-americans
go back to go to Liberia Marcus Garvey
is best known for his attire he wore a a
tri-corner hat which is what was worn
and we don't know we have a picture of
him up Peter I can't we yes we do yeah
we're gonna put a picture of him up to
okay here in a second and he had a he
had a great problem in being taken
seriously by some people because of the
way he dressed his J Edgar Hoover was
very troubled by him because he was such
a powerful speaker once he got 25,000
people into the old old Madison Square
Garden and Hoover was just afraid afraid
of a man whose vocal power was so great
that it could rise such emotions among
you know people like African Americans
and as Hoover knew you couldn't trust
people like that so he had Garvey very
carefully watched eventually charged him
with
embezzlement and and other crimes it is
not clear to this day whether Garvey was
innocent the best guess would be he
wasn't that it was Hoover being Hoover
and eventually he was he was deported
and his scheme to have a his own fleet
of ships that would carry Africa African
Americans out of this country to Liberia
failed text message Craig in Sacramento
with the avalanche of data for
historians now how do you see them
coping with processing at all in coming
up with coherent histories sir more data
now today than there was more historical
data I I don't know I know that it's
more easily accessible it used to be
when I first started writing history you
know I went to the Benjamin Franklin
collection at the Abenaki library at
Yale I believe it's at the by Nicki and
I've gone to a lot of you know the
Theodore Roosevelt collection lots of
collections now a great number of those
are online and you can just sit in your
home and get the information I would say
for a historian no it can't be
considered a problem to have too much
information maybe what it does is make
you more careful in what information you
select for instance if if somebody has
compiled all the tweets about Thomas
Jefferson you can probably skip that but
if there is more information than its us
it'll take you a little longer to write
the book but since that information is
more easily gotten maybe it won't take
you a little longer because you can get
it online so that's ID I don't think
that's a problem dan is in Bridgewater
New Jersey dan please go ahead with your
question or comment for author Eric
Byrnes two questions the first one I was
raised in Europe so far history was sort
of the glue that holds us together the
rail on which the nation moves and so
forth and
when I came here I found very little
patches or history in fact it used to be
said that anybody who wanted to stay in
academia and couldn't tell college
algebra
you'd usually go into history because
there you didn't have to know
quantitative special interests on
pacifically so anything that raises the
question about technical know-how of
most historians to deal with technical
resolutions that happen only failest a
solution and the second question was
typically my aesthetic studies first
knocking could you tell me why you think
like the Cold War which the assistant
title a lot of us maybe saw enough kids
didn't go to it that certainly is of
something that evolved because of the
direction is technology not lasting but
it's just nothing to discuss today it
was just something that was in the hands
of her advocates on one side of another
we can look back on it you really
thought it was already through us nobody
seems to be interested get more
interested in alright thank you Dan in
Bridgewater New Jersey Eric Byrnes well
he fired quite a bit of ammunition out
there the thought that came primarily to
my mind is that the problem if there are
problems with historians there are
greater for want of a better word
problems with people who don't have a
great deal of interest in history
sometimes if you're a historian you can
have difficulty finding an agent because
the agent thinks he or she won't be able
to sell your book if he or she is able
to sell your book to a publisher it
won't be for enough money to make it
worthwhile for the agent to get his or
her 15% and
to me the the the problem goes back at
least in my experience to the way
history is taught the way history was
taught in in public schools
it was taught without any enthusiasm for
me it was taught without any relevance
which is to say is there a way and the
answer is always yes is there a way to
tie this historical event to the present
what can we learn about the present from
this historical event history seemed to
attract the the the dullest the least
interested of the teachers I happen to
know of a woman who teaches fourth grade
and teaches history and every other
subject and she and the people she
worked with make history
a viable living thing by having the
students act out parts they're studying
believe it or not in fourth grade the
the Silk Road well students are
stationed so to speak at various points
along the Silk Road and they're doing
reports on it television reports they're
making maps the if if if you do this
kind of thing if if if if you put the
students into the history as opposed to
read the history at the students I think
everything changes after that and you
become more interested as an adult in to
use the example we just heard lingering
effects if there are any and are some of
the Cold War Steve in Stafford Virginia
text message Eric I'm embarrassed to
admit that as an avid nonfiction reader
I haven't read any of your books which
one would you recommend that I start
with well Steve I
is that a text yes I don't know much
about technology of a phone yeah but
it's a flip-up I'm what what I'd like to
do is know that whether or not I could
find out what's something about Steve's
interests that's Steve in Stafford if
you can follow up that text and send us
another one and tell us what your
interests are and we'll go from there
and in the meantime we'll talk to Thomas
and Greencastle PA hello Eric I'm a
historian and I have watched over the
over time the presidential nonpartisan
rankings which evaluated presidents each
year my question to you is why President
Dwight Eisenhower is now ranked fifth
behind Lincoln Washington FDR and
Theodore Roosevelt well could I just
change things around you can riff all
you want on that ask you the same thing
I have no idea I'd like to know who
ranked him there I'm baffled
do you mind having a guest who's baffled
Peter where would you rank the
presidents given what you've read
studied you know the traditionalists
Washington Lincoln so let's put those
two out of the way forgetting those four
getting those two who else have you read
about worked on research that caught
your attention let me say this I think
the three most interesting interesting
and that's a value neutral word
interesting men ever to serve in the
White House served consecutively let me
make it a question for you Peter
they served consecutively in our
lifetime Kennedy Johnson Nixon nicely
done
they are the presidents along with
Roosevelt and Washington and Lincoln
about whom I have the most books
Nixon did Tom wicker the liberal
columnist of New York Times once wrote a
book called one of us it was a biography
of Nixon and by one of us he meant he's
a liberal and he was the people who hate
him don't know that affirmative action
Richard Nixon food stamps Richard Nixon
opening the doorway to China Richard
Nixon I'm not advocating that Richard
Nixon was a good moral man I'm simply
telling you that this was one of the
joys for me of reading history to to to
see the complete Richard Nixon to know
that the most powerful figure at least
in my lifetime and certainly in the
twentieth century which is to say that
the the man who had the most potential
to affect the course of this country was
Lyndon Johnson Lyndon Johnson's power
over Congress was monumental and he said
once to someone wouldn't it be wouldn't
wouldn't wouldn't wouldn't it be a shame
if I got known for this this was his
word pissant little war in Asia instead
of what I'm trying to do at home and of
course Kennedy for his various
transgressions his his sex appeal many
other things I find those three the most
interesting I would put none of them on
Mount Rushmore and from the book
invasion of the mind Snatchers a
connection here the 1952 presidential
campaign in what was spent on television
seven point three million dollars was
spent by the Republicans to elect Dwight
Eisenhower a quarter of that amount
going to television the Democrats only
had two million to spend and in 2004 it
was estimated that fully fifty five
percent of the money spent by the two
parties during
the presidential campaign went for
television mark Dana Point California in
Orange County hi mark hi I was
fascinated by your comment about how
common the drinking was among our
founding fathers and the population as a
whole at that time I've heard that the
average consumption by men was about two
pints a day of alcohol and the idea that
it was somehow a medicinal that you
brought out I found very enlightening
that thinking still goes on today
because mistaken studies that it's now
believed that one or two drinks a day is
actually healthy but those studies 54 of
them are all flawed
I wondered if you're thinking about
doing some more writing about alcohol
and how it damages society historically
as well as today thank you for your
comment about the book the answer is no
I've I've written really all I have to
say about the history of alcohol there's
certainly much more to be said because I
stopped writing I think in 1959 when
Oklahoma became the last state to repeal
prohibition as I said I I don't know why
but I just don't like to get too close
to the present it's bad enough to have
to live in it I certainly don't have to
write about it so I think I'm done with
alcohol and what the American Library
Association I believe it was gave awards
to both the spirits of America a social
history of alcohol and the smoke of the
gods a social history of tobacco and
you're the only non academic
non-academic to win that award twice
yeah the award is called the best of the
best it's for those are the only two
books I've published with an academic
house which means peer review which
means that as as awful as most academic
books are because of how academics right
I don't write that way so my books are
safe to read but you can trust them
because they have been you can probably
trust them they've been read very very
carefully by two people who are experts
in in the field and that happens before
you you have a deal with the publisher
but yes they were called the best of the
best for their years and I was and
remain very much honored at one point
fifty percent of all men you write smoke
cigarettes in this country about thirty
five percent of women today it's about
twenty five percent men and twenty-one
percent of all the women mark I'm sorry
we just had mark and we're gonna move
down to Sam in North Pole Alaska hi Sam
hello sir my comment is regarding on
Americans paying attention history
actually learning from it Tom it's not
an American tradition we look at Vietnam
we were lied into that war may be that
information came out later the gulf of
tonkin was basically fabricated ten
years later lied in to the war in iraq
and just recently came out with the
Hillary Clinton emails we were lied in
to the overthrow of Gaddafi in Libya
which was just an utter disaster so
that's not something Americans do is
actually learn from a past not mistakes
yeah but you learned you learned didn't
you you must have learned from someone a
journalist or a historian because you
know about these lies absolutely not
you know I think a growing number of
people are waking up but we still let it
happen over and over again I mean it was
just you know eight years after the war
a lot that the same thing happened to
Libya and it's just as great that she's
actually it's probably gonna be the next
president that qualifies or not anything
else its reward policy and real quick
that's one of his back to Woodrow Wilson
one of the worst presence we've ever had
and thank income tax Federal Reserve
World War one all terrible things in our
history and thank you both for taking
time with some news there thanks Sam
thank you
yes well to go back to Woodrow Wilson
in your book 1920 you talked about how
he was not very adept at politics when
he became President of Princeton that he
was not very good at it at all on campus
politics right campus politics it had to
learn let me say first of all the
Woodrow Wilson although he was in favor
of the income tax
he didn't originate the first income tax
of any significance in this country the
kind of income tax we have today started
in 1913 and that no that is Wilson isn't
it gosh I lost myself Numerical depends
on what month it is yeah no I'm sorry he
took office March of 1913 so that's
right right my apologies that's right
but the the momentum certainly for that
had had built the the the financial need
was already there Wilson didn't just out
of nowhere come over for the idea for
the income tax the momentum carried
Wilson to the income tax braun is
calling in from randall Washington Ron
please go ahead you're on book TV yes
mr. burns you have any appreciation of
the writings of Ernest Hemingway why do
you add Ron why do you ask that question
well I just I just love his his life do
you know what about his writing he lived
it do you like his writing as well not
as much why except well I'll feel up to
a few as far as like the old man and see
but I appreciate to his history of his
life his home his biographies the people
he used to run around with the
expatriates
is a pound just got the Fitzgerald and I
was just wondering what mr. burns
thought of them as a Hemingway Ron thank
you for that thank you for that
well ii-i've never liked Hemingway as an
author I think he's monumentally
overrated in terms of being a human
being he could be a terrible human being
f scott Fitzgerald got Hemingway his
first publishing contract by begging his
editor trading Fitzgerald was doing
trading on his good name with his editor
at scribblers to publish Hemingway's
first book and Hemingway spent years
trashing just savaging verbally
Fitzgerald and to say you admire how he
lived his life because of the people
that he knew we can't go over all the
people that he knew but it's it's hard
to admire a life really admire a life
don't you think Peter that ended the way
Hemingway's did well to answer that I'm
gonna go to your joy of books book this
is the joy of books list I am NOT a
literary critic not an academic not a
regular contributor to the New York
Review of Books which is to say that in
my reading I am strictly an amateur but
an amateur in the best sense of the
world word it is in this spirit touting
my strengths confessing my weaknesses
that I present a list of 572 books that
have given me joy over the years and one
of those books is the Sun Also Rises by
Ernest Hemingway and you list the Great
Gatsby and Tender is the night by F
scott Fitzgerald The Sun Also Rises yeah
could you give a pen I do exit out
seriously it's one I don't I have no
idea how that got there I read it again
so a books list Eric burns maybe I felt
compelled to put something by Hemingway
I read read it again ready
second time about three or four years
ago and so we'll take that out for the
gay across that out here's the plot some
people go to a party and get drunk and
say let's go to another party and get
drunk and then they go to that other
party and get drunk and someone says
let's go to another party and get drunk
and then someone says well there's a
bull fight going on let's go to the bull
fight and get drunk and they watch the
bull fight and get drunk and then come
back to wherever the hell they are Paris
and and and get drunk some more that's
the plot of the Sun Also Rises so there
are some some what we would consider
classics in here but there's also some
contemporaries on the fiction list yes
and that includes Tom Wolfe for Scott
Turow
Robert Frost yes why are they on there
Scott Turow I mean you don't you think
of him was kind of a suspense or
thriller writer right well Stephen
King's on there as well Stephen King is
a superb writer it took him a long time
to be recognized as that you know the
New York Times finally two or three
years ago picked it's five best fiction
books of the year one of them was
11/22/63 which was by Stephen King and
that's the date that Kennedy died I
I wished that King would just hold back
a little with a certain folksy quality
that he has to him that goes to me a
little bit too far but III said after I
read the first few of his books that
when people think of horror eventually
they will think of Stephen King they
will not think of Edgar Allan Poe and I
have to tell you I have in my library at
home I wrote Stephen King a note 31
years ago I was with NBC and I said I
travel a lot I enjoy your books
something like that and it just finished
publishing Christine and he said it's
interesting that I should hear from
someone I and he put it in quotes no
because I just saw you at Three Mile
Island and
that's but the one thing that I would
never be able to write about is nuclear
power run amok I appreciate your report
and I look forward to reading more of
you I've been offered so much money for
that
because it's it's Stephen King admitting
that there's one thing that frightens
him so much he won't write about it 31
years have passed he's never written
about it so you did he's a good writer
March 29th 1979 you write 3-mile was I
how do you know that and I don't know
well that's the date that it occurred Oh
or the day after my god you're prepared
so so I was there yes how close were you
allowed to get to that to the reactors
well enough so that they they were in
the background
they were clearly seen in the background
I don't think Three Mile Island if I
remember correctly was ever as dangerous
as the media with their sensationalistic
bent made that out to be although it you
know it was certainly not to be taken
lightly but I remember being a little
surprised at being able to get as close
as I was and a little unwilling to get
any closer Bunny in Indiana asks via
text message what subject have you not
written about but would like to I would
like to write about either I would like
to write about the del Vikings the del
Vikings are a doo-wop group from the 60s
who recorded my favorite piece of music
in history and this includes Beethoven
and Mozart and diminishes any regard you
might have for my sophistication and
intellectual background the song has
come go with me and I tried to get in
touch with them they were the first
integrated group they met at an Air
Force Station to make the Billboard Top
10 and they did it with my favorite song
and I was able to get in touch with them
but we just couldn't work it out they
didn't I don't know if they
they didn't believe me or what I wanted
to do was tie in the Dell Vikings who
were from Pittsburgh and and I did a
piece on them for the for the Today Show
once which is how I had the contacts for
them
I wanted to tie their story in with the
story of what was happening to
Pittsburgh at the time and the steel
industry I have some ideas for a
connection but I'd love to write either
that book or the same kind of book about
the Marcel's who recorded blue moon
let me also in my defense say that I
really do like a great deal of classical
music and have tickets for the
Metropolitan Opera in early April back
to your 572 books on the joy of books
list some of the contemporary nonfiction
authors that you include include Paul
Johnson Doris Kearns Goodwin David
McCullough Peter Collier and David
Horowitz too conservative writers and
Albert Speer inside the Third Reich well
it certainly wasn't an wasn't an
endorsement of his policies but inside
the Third Reich is a fascinating
fascinating book one of the things that
I remember was the Hitler's concern not
just for architecture but for interior
design that his office was long and
narrow so that when you entered you had
a long walk to get to him plenty of time
to be intimidated his desk was up on a
platform it was a tall desk his chair
was raised so he he wanted a setting
which would completely dominate the most
self-confident of people and he he was
greatly interested in architecture as a
means of cowing the population because
of a show
of a marble power so it's fascinating
book Anthony New York City thanks for
holding your own with author Eric burns
hi mr. burns I'm enjoying this program
very much
I had asked a question to the person who
answered the phone what you might think
of HL Mencken and Bill Buckley now I
knew Bill Buckley and I'm a member of
the Menken Society but your opinion on
those two people would be of interest
how did you know Bill I William Buckley
I ran for office with his brother James
when James was elected senator I ran for
New York State Controller I didn't win
because I was running against awful
Leavitt but I got to know the Buckley
family I knew the late priscila and a
marvelous family and I got to know bill
over the years several articles
published a National Review and I just
was a great admirer of his too those are
two names that are also on your joy of
books less by the way well I know but I
I knew bill as well not very well I had
done a couple of stories related to him
but HL Mencken just delights me just
he's the only American writer I know who
I can identify whose style I can
identify after a couple of sentences you
give me two or three sentences plucked
anywhere from anything he wrote and I
will know it's Menken that's how
different he was that's what a master he
was of using the English language he was
not someone you wanted as an enemy
because verbally he was he was as
acerbic as could be but just his name
makes me smile if you haven't read
Menken or read about Menken and you care
about the language you're you're missing
something that you shouldn't be missing
did he write about politics politics oh
yes yes he loved to cover elections
because he loved to diminish all of the
candidates he never said
a good word about any of the candidates
I'm thinking uh whose oratory wasn't I
Harding maybe the Menken described
Harding's oratory is something like a
string of wet sponges I'm not doing
justice to it that it's it's just like a
string of wet sponges tied together he
did it better than that but he could he
could he could think the way no one else
thinks his metaphors his similes his
comparisons a delight I love Meghan I
have every book he ever wrote and I have
every biography about Kent
Irving Texas hi Kent I think you're one
to thank you for the great job you're
doing
you always are prepared this has been
alluded to several times by mr. burns I
want to thank mr. burns for coming on
and sharing his wisdom and knowledge
about the history as well as just
comments on his books
Natalie probably realized it was going
to be uncomfortable which it obviously
has and it's been a great show look TV
is just such an asset to the country and
that's about all I had to say I want
though I appreciate y'all's candor and
some of the things that you touch going
I know something pops into my mind it's
one of the funniest Oh probably fairly
serious too is about history and the way
it's been written about is like our
founding fathers were such righteous
people and heroes there are actually
traitors of the English government right
I never sent here their trips were paid
for and I think Washington worked with a
man named mr. MacFarlane which was hired
by the British government to survey the
land which they ended up with a lot of
so anyway it's just pretty ironic but
that's people love me take care
Kent thanks for calling you let me make
a point about the the the Stamp Act to
call the
founding fathers traders is not as
treasonous a statement as it sounds the
Stamp Act I think more than any other a
single sin if you will committed by the
British government toward the colonies
fired the colonies and Sam Adams above
whom we talked earlier to rebellion but
the Stamp Act
first of all everybody in Great Britain
paid the same tax exactly the same tax
on documents as we were asked to pay in
this country
we had free protection from in the
French and Indian War from British
troops and the Stamp Act was way of
getting back some of that money the
Stamp Act should not have been a cause
of rebellion and I have found myself
thinking as I as I have written about it
especially in infamous scribblers
because I was writing about how the
Stamp Act was written about that if that
if any if it had been perceived fairly
and paid as we owed it for what Great
Britain had done for us my god what
would the course of history be would
there have been still been a war if if
the primary cause didn't exist well that
kind of goes to what kneel in Charlotte
North Carolina texts into you mr. burns
in the view of the many moments in
history which seemed to turn on timing
alone have you ever entertained thoughts
of the course of the American Revolution
had it occurred in a different time no
I've never thought about the revolution
occurring at a different time as I said
I've thought about it not occurring
there were other grievances that we had
that other than the Stamp Act that were
more legitimate but as I said the the
primary
cause of the incitement the journalistic
incitement for war was the Stamp Act and
the Stamp Act was fair it was fair Peter
Bob's in Stony Creek New York hi Bob
hello we're listening sir go ahead oh
I'm sorry I thought you were okay - Eric
Byrnes have you ever considered teaching
history in the evening division of a
college the reason I ask is that I was
subjected to boring history teachers who
put me to sleep at nine o'clock at night
you would not have been one of them
thank you very much yes I have thought
about it I have contacted a few colleges
in the area where I live which is
Fairfield County Connecticut and haven't
even gotten the courtesy of a reply
I suspect that I'm far more qualified to
be an adjunct professor of history than
a lot of people who are I'd like to do
it on a part-time basis because I like
to share any one I think likes to share
his enthusiasm and the college's in in
my neighborhood don't seem to be
interested not even a courtesy
not even the courtesy of a reply no why
do you think that is I don't know I
don't know one person wrote back to me
and you know I said attached is my
resume and if somebody wrote back and
said you know we don't have an opening
now with it by the way in academia we
call a resume a CV what is the
curriculum vitae and I wrote back and I
said fine you call it what you want I'm
not an academic attached is my resume I
probably wasn't getting that position
Jim in Anchorage Alaska hi Jim well
thanks for taking my call based on your
study of history in the United States
I'd like to know what your thoughts are
concerning the Middle East and not what
we could have or should have done but
based on historical facts to date for
the United States going forward what in
your opinion should be our approach to
the Middle East I'm not qualified to
answer that question I'm not John in
Winfield Alabama text message as someone
who taught elementary age writing
classes
I wonder what children's books if any
were special to you what have you
written that you felt like really
captured your voice as a writer and who
did you first read that made you want to
write so children's books your voice is
a writer and who are those first
influences well I'll still forget one of
them I'm very absent-minded but as
William James once said absent
mindedness is president mindedness
somewhere else so that's my excuse the
only my parents weren't or both school
teachers taught music and math never saw
either one of them read a book I don't
remember books being read to me although
that might just be my memory which
kicked in in a very poor gear when I was
very young Peter Pan comes to mind
okay what's second when did you find
your voice as a writer do you think it
took me longer than it takes most people
I think I had to get fiction out of my
system the idea of being a great
novelist I was probably in my 30s my mid
30s and frankly and I think this is this
is something that any author who cares
about his work should say I think I'm
still trying to find it or trying to
keep it when I get up in the morning my
goal is to write that day
perfect prose and when I'm finished with
a book to write a perfect book I never
will and that's great because I have a
constant incentive to do better because
I'll never reach my goal
do you write every day yes how long if
things go well I can write for four or
five hours if not I'll stop earlier but
it's really if you if you think a lot
you get physically tired and I think a
lot when I write and it's physically
tiring what's the third it was related
to the first two when did you get the
idea to start writing who are the
writers that got o idea to start writer
writers didn't do that it was just me I
wanted to write before I had writers
whom I admired if you remember Stephen
Stafford you asked yes next yes yes yes
Steve wants to know which one of your
books that to start with and you asked
what his interests were my primary
interest is US history and prominent US
characters in history in the 20th
century okay I'll give you I'll give you
two
Steve's start with this would be easier
to get because it's a recent read 1920
the year that made the decade roar
probably not in the stores anymore it
came out last May but easily is there a
paperback edition come on in the
paperback will be out in August
fortunately I am happy to say the
hardcover sales have been good enough
that the paperback has been delayed so
you can wait till August if you want
also I think you would find the book
invasion of the mind Snatchers what's
the subtitle televisions invasion
televisions conquest of America and
50s yep did I get it you write it you
got it you write it enough and sometimes
the titles of your book escape you that
you'd have that's that book is six years
old you'd have to get that through
Amazon so those two books and I thank
you for your seriousness for your taking
my question to you seriously about your
interest so I could recommend and you
were writing back I appreciate that give
and take Christina and McLean Virginia
hi Christina please go ahead with your
question or comment for Eric burns and I
was surprised to hear you say that you
couldn't admire Hemingway because of his
suicide and I wondered if you felt the
same about all the other authors who
ended their lives in the same same way
like Virginia Woolf and Sylvia Plath
cetera et cetera you know I think that's
a great question because and I'd have to
think about it the reason is that you
what you may have done is you may have
cut me in in a bias there I don't I
never thought much of Hemingway as as a
writer and I've read everything he's
written and this false or maybe it was
genuine but machismo which was his code
of life I thought was really tedious but
in asking the question you asked I guess
I would have to know more about Sylvia
Plath life about Virginia Woolf life but
it may be that you caught me in anti
Hemingway bias and that I would have
more admiration for some others so I
applaud you for that that's a very good
question and it's something worth my
thinking about Bob is in Thousand Oaks
California hi Bob hi you mentioned that
you're from Pittsburgh and I'm an Old
West ender I don't know if you're
familiar with the West End of Pittsburgh
I have a question for you though about
Albert Speers book inside the Third
Reich and I remember distinctly reading
in that
where he said that the Germans never had
a chance to win world war two and in
fact the biggest single problem that
they had in Russia
unbelievably was a shortage of horses do
you remember reading that in that book
no I don't it's been in too many year
too many years I don't remember the
shortage of horses I do remember his
view about and not thinking that the
Germans could could win but obviously
you found it interesting as well well
Beverly emails into you
Beverly Scofield Santa Maria California
I am a writer who finally published my
first book at the age of 75 my interest
seems to be in writing fiction set in
historical events what is your opinion
about historical fiction as a genre when
I read about history I want to know the
history I want to know the truth so I
don't read much historical fiction
because I never know what to believe
that being said one of the best books
I've ever read in my life which came up
earlier was ed dr. oz the late ed doctor
of ragtime and it was pretty easy to
tell in that book what was fiction and
what was nonfiction you know when Henry
Ford or somebody like that I don't
remember was showing up at a characters
house at the house of a person who
didn't exist well you know that didn't
happen so there is a way to write
historical fiction and not confuse the
reader if you can do that fine but if
you confuse the reader by just twisting
events a little bit making them happen
at a different time making them happen
in a different way
I I don't care for that kind of thing
because if the subject ever comes up
even just in my mind I want to know the
truth Henry Ford makes an appearance in
the spirits of America Henry Ford also
favored abstention you write
the Jews he thought were trying to
conquer the world through the use of
liquor two befuddled the brains of
Christian leaders and the automaker
would not let it happen
well Henry Ford was a notorious
anti-semite and notoriously ignorant
about virtually anything his opinions
are certainly not to be taken seriously
his cars are let's leave it at that you
can drive a Ford just don't listen to
anything Henry said Rick and Pompano
Beach Florida hi Rick yes good afternoon
what a shame we don't have more authors
and writers like mr. burns I was
wondering on his list of authors where
Graham Greene fell into that category
yes
Yeah right Rick Rick yes
what do you why do you like Graham
Greene I am The Quiet American I don't
know if you ever wrote the book I read
the book excuse me all right thank you I
think there's a long list of Graham
Greene books and there isn't isn't there
there's a couple different lists and I'm
looking at them he wasn't on nonfiction
no he didn't write write
he wrote wanted to be from the end of
the affair the human factor the Ministry
of fear the quiet American and travels
with my aunt travels with my aunt which
was nonfiction by the way but yes I had
a great admiration for Graham Greene
Troy is in Bethel Missouri
Troy you are on book TV please go ahead
she's a pleasure to talk to you sir I
really respect your work and you reached
her true calling when you got to look TV
mr. Barnes I thought it was great that
you mentioned that you were fascinated
by Richard Nixon earlier in the program
because I too am fascinated by the man I
think he's probably the most brilliant
politician in my lifetime and I turned
50 last month I thought Tom whicker's
book was outstanding you mentioned it to
overlayer one of us it's one of my
personal favorites but
where would you rank Harry Truman in
terms of presidential rankings sis I I
admire that man too and I think I
couldn't rank and you know probably
about fourth is where I'd go you guys
had a good day that's Troy in Missouri
that goes back to where we began
journalism as a first draft yeah but I I
want to answer that off to the side a
little bit I don't know where I drank
Truman but here's a wonderful story
about German Truman was a haberdasher
you know he was just an average guy and
his secretary of state was Dean Acheson
who had a long mustache that curled up
at the ends who care who walked with a
cane didn't need a cane it was an
affectation went to Yale all of all of
the prep schools was was the was
antithetical in every way to Harry
Truman and Harry Truman used to use big
words when he talked to a schism
polysyllabic words and mispronounced
them and Acheson said that that was one
of the reasons he admired Truman so much
because it proved the Truman although he
had no compatriots who shared his
intellectual interests and who would
know how to pronounce the words that he
was reading kept that at anyhow because
he wanted to learn and Acheson would
subtly correct him and admire him for
that a book which I don't think has been
written about the relationship the
friendship between these two very
unlikely people would be a wonderful
piece of reading Eric Byrnes if somebody
wants to contact you do you have a
website or a way for them to email you I
don't have a website no I am what I
would suggest is you know I don't you
don't have to suggest anything do I have
I'm just wondering if my publisher has a
website because oh sure we'll have a
website if you go to the back you'll see
that probably who's a publisher okay
was that well it's a the books are
distributed by Norton a Pegasus the
flying horse PE GA s us there will be a
WWE Pegasus comm I guess and they would
forward anything to me but as I'm a true
historian in that I am a Luddite and and
and I just I mean I'm i tec technology
and I are not simpatico our book readers
Luddites not necessarily know Doug
Silver Spring Maryland hi Doug
good afternoon getting back to HL
Mencken a really really fine writer but
the thing that I've always found
disturbing about him is he can be
incredibly vicious and I find sort of
wonder aren't there other cases a little
bounce I'm thinking specifically of his
of his piece on William Jennings Bryan
after his death well anyway but the
bottom line is sometimes I just find him
a little too vicious and I find that
disturbing and I'd like to hear your
your comment thank you very much thank
you very much it's pretty it's probably
a point no it's not probably a point
it's definitely a point I should have
made and sometimes all of us who are
writers and have our certain stylistic
shall we say quirks go too far with them
yes I agree with you Menken went too far
what he said about Bryan he was entitled
to say but to say it as an obituary was
really to go too far and you're right
what what what's so great about reading
Megan is how he savages the pomposity of
politicians which means he's always on
the edge of going too far and you're
right there times when he goes over the
edge Robert Young email earlier you
allowed that you wouldn't trust writings
by either
publicans or Democrats presumably on
historical subjects then a bit later you
reference I and ran Freudian slip either
in support of her view or an opposition
further is it at all possible to write
history on a blank slate well I have no
idea about the island reference that had
to do with the fact that she would have
appreciated the black sugar wouldn't
have affected her because she would have
appreciated the industry and I don't
know what it means storage history on a
blank slate well I think I do yeah
no I mean we're all humans and we have
our opinions what I I don't know that I
said I wouldn't trust a book by a
Republican or a Democrat because most
people are registered in the party I I
wouldn't trust books that are written if
there's a point of view it should come
out of the book I don't I don't want
anybody to go into a book for the point
of view and Coulter I I wouldn't read a
book by an Coulter if it were all about
what a wonderful guy that I am people
who have established reputations on one
side of the aisle or the other you know
there are liberal and Coulter's god
forbid but those people there's no point
in reading books by them George will a
conservative has just severely
criticized Ann Coulter's books for her
errors linda tweets into you and she may
not have been listening earlier but
maybe she was how would you compare
Abraham Lincoln to Teddy Roosevelt as
fathers during their White House years
Teddy Roosevelt was a better father
Teddy Roosevelt I don't know how Teddy
Roosevelt did what he did in 24 hours a
day but Teddy Roosevelt ran through the
White House grabbing the kids playing us
what they called scary bear pillow
fights were to the Roosevelt's of
Sagamore Hill what touch football was to
the kennedys of Hyannisport
and Roosevelt let his kids Quentin came
in once with snakes wrapped around him
well a snake wrapped around one arm a
snake wrapped around the other snake
wrapped around his neck Theodore was at
the time talking to his Secretary of War
and looked at him said why don't you go
next door they're a couple of
congressmen waiting to see me and just
go chat with them and so that's what
what happened Theodore sent a man to
scare the hell out of these congressmen
no I know I'm not saying that there
weren't parents fathers who love their
children as much but no one gave the the
time the Theodore did either in person
the direct playfulness or epistle airily
when when the children went away to
school the book 1920 why why the
Flatiron Building on the cover I don't
know the artist did that and I thought
it looked good
now it wasn't in 1921 the Flatiron
Building caught fire they believed that
was 1913 I thought this year was built
something like that was it okay it was
before 1920 that the fire happened I
have no idea I
that's the dust jacket he submitted I
thought it looked great so did everybody
else Jim is in Woodruff South Carolina
hi Jim dad Jim we're listening yeah Eric
had read any of Thomas Wolfe's books and
I had met Thomas Wolfe's brother back in
the fifties when I was a child his name
was Ted Wilson in the look homeward
angel book he was Luke and Luke uttered
and Fred wolf actually stuttered in real
life
and I was wondering if he thought that
the city of Asheville got very angry
about his writings of his books well
talk about Tom Wolfe because he's listed
in your joy of books as well no he's not
it's the other Tom Wolfe oh I'm sorry
you know the the younger Tom Wolfe
Thomas Wolfe is someone who I never
really appreciated because of the for
the same reason I don't appreciate the
plays of Eugene O'Neill I think there's
a just an undue verbosity that that puts
me off but I do know from historical
reading that yes the city of Asheville
was for a time very upset with its
native son for how it was portrayed
that's true I apologize it is Tom Wolfe
bonfire the vanities is listed as one of
the 572 books and I think virtually
every one of his non-fiction books is in
there too I've read them all but bonfire
of the vanities was the only a work of
fiction he'd written at that time
although I probably wouldn't have listed
the other two they're not they're not as
good I don't think well speaking of
plays and playwrights what's mid strut
mid strut is my first play which one the
Eudora Welty Eudora Welty emerging
playwrights competition in 2010 had its
first production at the Pittsburgh
Playhouse coincidentally in 2012 and
here in 2016 it still awaits its second
production
I finished the second play which is
perhaps moving close to a production I
I'm I'm I'm when I grow up I would like
to be a playwright because at the end of
the lonely process of writing I loved
the communal aspect of working with good
actors talking about what I had done and
it was like having a party after a being
in solitary confinement for a long time
writings lonely what's the theme of the
mid struttin if I stand up will that
throw the camera off right I don't know
if it'll throw the camera off I'll go
for it Francis just be careful of your
mic and your piece there's those are the
two things you have to be a careful of
this buddy first don't leave I'm doing
this this is the position you normally
think of when you think of a majorette
all right one leg up the mate that the
baton under here and I decided to call
this mid strut it's about a guy who
finds out he has six months left to live
and has to decide what would be most
valuable to do in those six months he
decides it would be to have sex with
he's in his 50s to have sex with a woman
who was a majorette in high school and
whom he admired from afar so turns out
she's married but her husband just had
his first affair so maybe she's ready to
listen and he comes and he says listen
it's you know nothing personal but I
just wondering if you'd have sex with me
and just once I don't want a
relationship just a one-night stand
because he's gonna die and and that's
all I say about because I'm hoping that
people will have a chance to find out
what happens after that Vince is in
Spotsylvania Virginia hi Vince
hello mr. burns to go back to HL Mencken
again you mentioned that you have all of
his books and I was wondering I'm not
trying
sharp shoot you but I was wondering if
you have ventures in diverse which is
probably his rarest book because at the
age I think he was 19 or 20
it was his attempt at prose and he was
so embarrassed by his effort that he
undertook to destroy as many of the
copies as he can so they're now very
rare
so as wondering if you have that and
also if you can comment on the attempt
of authors who are brilliant SAS or
commentators and who attempt to write
prose and what that process is like and
how successful it is well they do write
prose I mean if you write essays you're
writing prose so I don't understand the
question
as far as that book by Menken is
concerned no I don't have that I never
heard of it as far as I'm concerned he
was successful in destroying the copies
Robert is in price Utah Robert you're on
book TV good afternoon good afternoon
mr. burns which book are you most proud
of and which one do you think is the
best example of your style of variety
you're going to have to answer that
without any help
well infamous scribblers the founding
fathers and the rowdy beginnings of
American journalism is I am told
considered the definitive work on the
subject I don't know it's the one that
I'd say is most representative of my
style gosh what's your favorite no my
favorites always the one that I'm
working on about this know the joy of
books I like the joy of books a lot yeah
because I wanted to cover every aspect
of the experience of reading from the
writers point of view to the readers
point of view and you know the talking
about it getting into why does a reader
read and what I said before about
characters changing over the years yeah
that that pleased me
I'm glad you you brought that up maybe
that's maybe that's it because it's it
deals with the something that has been
my entire life and infamous scribblers
was a I think I saw somewhere that
that's been your best seller of all your
books maybe I'm wrong about that yeah
1920 will be congratulations Anthony and
Shirley New York hi Anthony yes hiya
Thank You c-span for taking my call and
thank you mr. Brown's fear of body of
work my question to you is do you ever
see the United States government as we
now know it today ever coming to an end
and if at some point in the future do
you ever see a democracy more thing into
something less democratic as the years
go by and thank you sir
you're welcome I'm not I said this once
before I'm not qualified to answer a
question like that and I don't think any
human being is I could take a guess but
you want to take that guess
I think the United States will
eventually be conquered by a country
which destroys our technology we will
not be taken over militarily we will be
taken over electronically because we
will not be able to communicate and
nothing that we depend on will work this
text message since you said you do not
understand technology how do you write
your books by longhand typewriter or
word processor word processor I what's
the most advanced thing I can do I can
cut and paste and you can get on the
internet I can get on the internet yeah
thank you
and obviously it's once you get on you
know what you get on word it's a it's a
it's a typewriter and I know how to save
it and I know how to click it and send
it to my agent but I don't know what a
spreadsheet is for instance I couldn't
do a spreadsheet you don't want one do
you Peter for me another text message
how mr. burns described HL Mencken is
exactly how I would describe burns I
wouldn't ever want to get on his bad
side I've thoroughly enjoyed listening
to him I find his fiery blunt candor
beautifully unsettling and deliberately
refreshing I wonder what HL Mencken was
like the interview beautifully
unsettling is a wonderful little phrase
isn't it thank you Frank
Las Vegas hi Frank hi how are you today
how are you sir Oh fine well tomorrow's
my birthday I'm coming up on 90 and what
I'm interested in is a book that I read
on all 50 years ago by Greenberg I
believe is Greenberg and it had to do
with only in America and he wrote that
Ward was anti-semitic but he discarded
anti-semitism and what happened was he
burned all the books that he had but I
never did find out you know
the years these years why he did that
mr. burns have you got any information
on that I'd appreciate it
Frank what have you done for a living
over your 90 years am i in 90 years the
biggest thing was electrical I was with
the Department of Water and Power in LA
as I ended up as a dispatcher electric
system role dispatcher and your comment
on the fact that electricity or the grid
it could be wiped out if we run into
that condition and that's something I've
read just or just heard about then the
lights out this book that was just
written here recently
Ted Conrad Ted Koppel's book thank you
you can watch it right first of all
Frank thanks for watching book TV thanks
for calling any sounds terrific Ted
Koppel appeared on book TV earlier a
couple months ago talking about his book
lights out you can go to book TV Norg
type in ted koppel book and you'll be
able to watch that online but to his
point Henry Ford did you have any I know
Henry Ford is kind of an aside and
you're in your writing so yeah it may
sound strange but well you said it he
has always been somewhat of an aside
I've never concentrated on him I I have
written at some length about the effect
of the automobile but not the
personality of Henry Ford if in fact
it's true that he burned all of his
anti-semitic books and you're asking me
for a reason I think there will only be
one reason you know that he he felt
finally felt a shame in his
anti-semitism and wanted to make a show
of it or wanted to make a show of it for
some other reason just because he wanted
to lower the temperature on himself I
don't know
Ronald Baltic Connecticut you have about
67 seconds
Wow hi that's not very much time but I
just wanted to know why we don't find
good writers that they explain exactly
the history in United States like the
processing in the Roman Catholics and me
coming from Spanish country I find that
it contradicts the history contradicts
the truth if you read the American
history from the cascara professor the
great Catholic thinking and scholars
something is missing
it doesn't coincide I do not understand
like the first amendment Congress shall
make no law respecting an establishment
of religion it is calling our countries
we understand the first amended
establishment of religions our
monasteries the church synagogue mosque
so we sell conviction make no law
against stability doesn't leave Ronald
Ronald we're gonna have to leave it
there I'm afraid any comment for that
caller mr. burns
no absolutely not I do you have one I
don't have to it's not you you don't
have to and I can't Eric burns has been
our guest for the last three hours well
he has several books out here was his
first broadcast blues that came out in
1993 his next book the joy of books
which we've referenced quite a bit
throughout this program the autograph
was a novel that he wrote here is the
spirits of America history of alcohol in
the United States infamous scribblers
smoke of the Gods was history of tobacco
virtue valor and vanity which you wanted
to name the founding fathers and their
pursuit of fame correct all the news
unfit to print about the news media
invasion of the mind Snatchers about
telev
in the 50s in 1920 the year that made
the day came out last year and his most
recent is golden lad about Quentin and
Theodore Roosevelt mr. Burnes thank you
for your time thanks for being on book
TV this is a wonderful program and to be
on it it's an honor and I thank you for
that